this video is sponsored by warframe
alrighty bleach time take two electric
boogaloo otherwise known as the soul
society arc i'm excited for this week
because we're diving headfirst into
material i haven't seen and furthermore
i just love getting past the first video
of these review series typically with my
first reviews in series i spend more
time recapping and giving context to
things i touch on youtube in part to
those first episodes acting as a sort of
jumping on point for many newcomers
hopefully those of you that are
interested in jumping into this series
have done so because from here on out
the training wheels are coming off and
i'll be giving substantially less recap
outside of areas that don't require it
in other words it's all killer no filler
as i attempt to understand breakdown and
review possibly the most popular arc in
all of bleach to tell you the truth i am
very excited and optimistic so without
further ado i'm totally not mark and
this is my review of bleach's soul
society arc
[Music]
[Applause]
so first things first damage control so
far only two names have been
mispronounced which might be a new
record for me i'm proud of myself it's
mr keys k not mr kiskay and you know
what that's my i'll hold it proudly but
i was certain i nailed tj kubo when i
said it but apparently it's tight or
title kubo that sounds strange and
weirdly sexual to me so i'm just gonna
call him kubo from here on out okay oh
also last week i went into detail
explaining why i preferred reading manga
over watching anime but due particularly
to the length of that particular video i
never quite got around to explaining why
i thought my experience with bleach's
anime and manga were so diametrically
different so i'll quickly give that a
shot here in addition to certain
characters being embellished to levels
that i would argue take more from the
characters than they otherwise give i
found personally the pacing and vibe of
the manga so much more inviting
oftentimes folks will complain about the
pacing of shows like one piece where it
roughly nowadays adapts about 75 percent
of a given chapter per episode of anime
however i think bleach has the opposite
problem at least in the first arc with a
single episode potentially adapting as
many as four or five chapters and due to
this roaring pace through the material
it serves to reason that only the
coolest moments got the love and
attention they deserve and as a result
comedic or more slice of life-centric
beats run the risk of feeling less
enjoyable and potentially more obnoxious
as they show up are skipped over or
roared on past at the pace the manga
didn't intend i'll give a quick example
of what i mean here chapter 50 is
roughly when ichigo unlocks his power
against the menos grande it's superbly
animated and it's one of the highlights
of the first arc for sure but that's
literally only episode 14 of the anime
meaning chapter 50 was adapted in
episode 14. ignoring whether it's a
better or worse experience for a second
to create pacing like that i think it's
fair to say that the two approaches
yield entirely different experiences and
i for one believe that's the real reason
i fell in love with the manga so quickly
compared to the anime now let me be
clear some shows can work really well at
adapting a ton of material at once per
episode and i'm not about to draw the
line in the sound suggesting that this
is a definitive problem every story has
different needs and every person has
their unique proclivities but i
definitely feel that for me the anime
gave ichigo's school life the short end
of the stick and it's a shame because
that was where i really fell in love
with the supporting cast as well as
their dynamic in the story all of which
helped to make ichigo feel much more
grounded as a result and so with that
said what are my expectations going into
this week's material well going into
this arc i have a certain amount to
consider and a certain number of
question marks i don't think i mentioned
this in my last video but the setting
for bleach's story is one of the many
things that set it apart from the other
members of the big three when i compare
them in my mind unlike one piece of
naruto who were both burdened with the
responsibility of disclosing and
explaining their world and cultures to
us in interesting ways bleach due to its
present-day japan type setting was free
to focus on exploring character dynamics
power systems as well as hint towards
the world that lay beyond the first arc
in the soul society in other words
bleach enjoyed a certain freedom one
piece and naruto didn't where their
respective settings forced them to
expand it so much about how their world
worked in their opening chapters bleach
didn't due to its more traditional
setting and world and therefore could
focus on what it wanted to do right off
the bat through fun and short stories
however now we reach the soul society a
setting that is by definition not of
this earth and so i'm keen to see how
efficient subtle and creative kubo can
be when disclosing necessary information
about the world and cultures of the soul
society to bring it to life through his
unique brand of world building we've
seen that he's capable of subtle and
tasteful writing in the last arc through
the likes of ichigo's friends and hints
towards the soul society not necessarily
being the arbiters of all that is
righteous and good in the world so
that's something i'm keeping an eye out
for too also this will by the looks of
things be the first arc to actually
assume a more solid traditional story
structure rather than the episodic style
shinigami arc that we got prior due to
these new variables there is a good
chance that this arc will feel entirely
different to the one i enjoyed prior in
key ways in other words kubo has to
juggle a number of different
responsibilities as an author and artist
that he otherwise didn't have to do in
the prior arc so with all that it said
let's see how this one plays out before
going any further i want to talk to you
about another awesome bit of animation
warframe really needs no introduction
it's one of the most popular online
action games with 70 million players
across its endless platforms and i could
not be more excited to partner with them
today for the launch of their 50th
warframe styenx available for free right
now digital extremes have partnered up
with animation studio passion paris to
produce one hell of an animated short
directed by the immensely talented david
pagai this thing is packed full of
creative layouts atmospheric color
choices wonderful compositing and of
course some of the finest animation this
year from its delicate character acting
to its dynamic action it's a real
powerhouse of a short and easy to see
why it took a team of 30 people a full
year to produce these five minutes of
stellar animation there's a link in the
description to the full short and i
really do encourage you to check it out
even if you've never played warframe
before it still has a hell of a lot of
impact what's great also is that just
like warframe itself styanax is
available entirely for free right now so
if you want to grab this mythical
javelin and shield wielding warrior use
my link down below to download the game
and log in to claim styanax before this
offer expires on september 21st i hope
you have a great time with the game and
enjoy the short as much as i did
well this arc kicks off with a bang and
i do mean a bang conventionally or at
least more often i've seen these raid
type stories from the likes of one piece
with impul down and onigishima where
infiltration into a new area is sort of
packaged as a slow build-up in the
narrative the same is true for stories
like the chimera ants arc of hunter
hunter covert ops can be entertaining
but to be honest i've always seen it as
perhaps more entertaining or at the very
least immediately interesting when
scenarios more akin to that of the
enemies lobby take place where the bad
guys know something is up right away and
await you to tackle them head on this is
such the case with the soul society arcs
beginning immediately and right off the
back of the first few pages the soul
society entrance way otherwise known as
koryu seems to be trying to kill them
alerting the guards of the trespassers
and where they are this creates
immediate tension and with us as readers
knowing about as much as these guys do
concerning the hostiles and strange
place that they're charging into it
helps us connect to and align more with
our main heroes by placing us in their
shoes furthermore when i read any given
chapter i try to look out for things i
might miss if i was reading this in my
leisure i noticed things that while
innocuous and small scale actually make
the story all that more effective take
for example this scene where they're
running away from the cleaner in seoul
society oreo is about to be picked off
but chad saves him throwing him over his
shoulder and that being totally in line
with his character in philosophy that we
touched on in the last video following
that urdu because he is now looking the
other direction alerts the gang to the
cleaner chasing and catching up to them
allowing orihime to make the save on
everyone despite understanding the
danger of doing so all of this is cause
and effect certainly which in and of
itself can be compelling however every
single component of what made this cause
and effect sequence work was also rooted
in established character traits whether
it be chad's kindness or to use
vulnerability or orihime selflessness
and quick thinking when using her power
to protect everyone at the last possible
moment all the while freeing up another
natural opportunity for mr cat to expose
it more about the world and how
dangerous that was specifically it's a
simple but very effective style of
naturally disclosing exposition about
the world of the soul society now i
won't be going through every decision
made in the manga like this but just
know that it is there and i very much
appreciate it with that said and in that
vein more generally i think the fashion
with which kubo has established and set
up these circumstances serves him very
well exposition is unavoidably something
every single story needs to do and it's
also one of the most difficult aspects
of it to pull off you don't want a
character to suddenly start monologuing
or speaking what otherwise would be
subtext like oh hello my good friend
we've been friends our entire life that
stuff sucks now this arc does have
characters that actually say stuff like
this and i'm not really a fan of that
but it's not so egregious and it doesn't
happen too often so i'm gonna let it
slide but at the same time creating
those scenarios for that natural
sounding exposition can be tough also in
this instance kubo's characters our main
four know and understand about as much
as we do concerning the soul society and
due to that any action they take that
might otherwise be ill-advised in this
territory can be pointed out to them
naturally by mr cat without feeling
forced or contrived to us and speaking
of ill-advised actions
following the frantic pace of the
opening similar to how covert missions
often don't go to plan and speed up this
one benefits from being stopped in its
tracks due to the time limit of rukia's
impending execution and the uncertainty
surrounding the complexity of the
journey ahead every moment is precious
and every delay could be catastrophic to
their plan and so this giant gin danbot
is a great mechanism to slow down the
frantic pace of this arc establish some
tension and perhaps most importantly
establish a sense of structure and
exposition for us as an audience in
other words on the other side of the
wall is a formidable adversary but to
get to them they need to overcome this
giant gatekeeper now this is a fun
albeit simple fight that serves to once
again communicate more about the world
to us through the giant's job how those
above and reprimand him and perhaps most
importantly how keen ichigo is to
continue his search for more experience
to use against his upcoming adversaries
all of this is great but this tussle
also utilizes something i generally love
that i've also recently learned is a
major criticism of the series
white space in backgrounds something i
noticed after the fallout of my last
review was that folks genuinely seemed
confused by my compliments towards the
paneling particularly towards kubo's use
of white space in the backgrounds
through some of my research i found that
a popular talking point or criticism of
his work is that very use of white space
that i previously complimented so i
guess that makes me the perfect person
to talk about it or at the very least
explain my point of view so here it goes
in short for me more isn't always better
and the degree to which that is true
will vary from person to person
dramatically people's tastes in art and
manga vary as wildly as an individual's
taste in music and food so from the
outset if you guys don't like his panels
because they're empty looking i can say
that you're wrong in the same way you
can say that i'm wrong for disliking the
taste of coca-cola if you happen to like
it we experience what we experience in
different ways and we aren't really in
control of that so why do i like it well
i mentioned akira toriyama's dragon ball
a number of times for a few reasons in
the last video and i did so because when
it comes to paneling his story is the
most well known and employs my favorite
philosophy when it comes to paneling
however it can also be observed in other
more modern mangas also chainsaw man is
another popular manga that leverages the
use of minimalistic backgrounds and
white space to strengthen aspects of its
series the best way i could describe
reading a chapter of chainsaw man would
be that of a fluid experience there are
a number of occasions in that very story
and in particular the paneling where
fujimoto depends on a reader's ability
to seamlessly and in a particular rhythm
read through his panels to evoke a
particular emotional response whether it
be shock or laughter and none of that
would be possible if the panels
themselves were harder to read or
decipher in a quick and seamless fashion
and to be clear this isn't to say that
dragon ball chainsaw man and bleach
don't have backgrounds they do in fact
chainsaw mine has some of the most
detailed backgrounds when they are
necessary but that's the key there are
plenty of instances where bleach uses
some detailed backgrounds and it serves
the story really well but just because
it doesn't use it all the time doesn't
necessarily mean that it's flawed in any
way placing the emphasis on characters
and not the background when it doesn't
matter to the story works exceptionally
well for me i like knowing at a glance
where the author wants my attention to
be so make no mistake the page
composition of a given manga page is a
curated and deliberate experience laid
out by the artist that designs it and so
for what i value in manga adding
backgrounds when they don't contribute
to the story and only really serve to
distract from the seamless rhythm of the
manga's key components its characters in
this case can only be a negative thing
for me however to play devil's advocate
as i mentioned the degree to which this
less is more style of layouts is
effective differs from reader to reader
it's no secret that millions around the
world love one piece and otis style when
it comes to drafting layouts for a page
they love to meticulously investigate
each and every panel in search of easter
eggs or secret plot elements and that
philosophy suits one piece's dedicated
reader base brilliantly the story is
very much designed to be something you
agonize and deliberate and discuss over
for hours with your friends so the more
oda can distract people from what's
actually going to happen will ultimately
aid him in delivering what the fans of
the series yearn for in a dork reveals
and surprises that shift the story to
the next level however that isn't
something i personally enjoy while i was
reading one piece for many of you you
already know this to turn the page only
to be greeted by dozens of panels
densely packed backgrounds and tons of
dialogue much of which was flavor only
served to push me further away as a
reader however when it comes to manga's
like dragon ball chainsaw man and as i'm
learning more and more bleach this less
is more or focused approach to paneling
really helps me glide through the story
in ways i look for as a reader with that
said as i mentioned with my criticism of
chapter one's opening with its lack of
establishing shot of who exactly was in
the scene clarity is what i value as a
reader when it comes to comics it's a
visual medium and if context that i
otherwise need to enjoy as seen to its
fullest potential isn't there i will
take an issue with it take this very
scene against the giant in chapter 73 as
an example the entire point of it is
ultimately about answering one question
and nothing else and that question is
can ichigo take these hits from this
giant from chapters prior we understand
where this is set what the area looks
like and so why should i care if there
are backgrounds here or not it's not
serving a function in the story any
longer and for one reason or another
whether it be due to weekly deadlines or
kubo not seeing them as right for the
scene there's white space implemented
and personally i think it's better for
it this isn't of course to suggest that
white space as a general rule is how i
prefer things and in the future it might
shape up to be used as a crutch rather
than a guiding philosophy or style and
if that does happen to be the case i
will call it out but this is generally
what i like the use of whitespace for
not because i enjoy seeing nothing but
because it forces me to focus my
attention exactly where the author wants
me to focus
overall i found this introductory
portion quite entertaining and effective
in what it needs to do to make this arc
a success it's not without a hiccup here
and there but all things considered i
think a performance duty very
effectively this intro consists of three
main sequences for our hero characters
this initial bout with the giant a
regrouping at a special location to prep
for going beyond the walls and finally
the preliminary cat and mouse games that
eventually undergo once they get in
there exposition and setup is the goal
of this introductory portion normally
however the trouble with setup and
exposition is that by default it can be
quite boring thankfully there are tons
of different ways to go about divulging
this necessary exposition while also
being entertaining dragon ball tends to
utilize extreme contrast to build
tension and use that as a means of
sneaking in exposition think the nomic
saga learning the ins and outs of the
frieza force and frieza himself through
the bouts of extreme contrast to hold
our attention and interest one piece is
also a master of pretty much every
aspect of exposition in fact i think oda
could probably write a book on that very
topic but some of my favorites come from
intriguing details being dropped out of
seemingly nowhere hunter hunter actually
performs this trick quite masterfully
too through gone's backstory being
filtered slowly out to us over the
course of the series it's the sort of
exposition that stops being a chore to
overcome and becomes something you beg
and almost wait for and that's for me
the best indication of a great story and
while bleach has made me ask questions
for sure i don't think i'm quite there
yet but i'm definitely on track to
feeling this way about the series as it
happens the tightest mangaka in all the
world mr kubo is no slouch when it comes
to exposition for the most part applying
and combining all of these techniques to
help him teach us about the world of the
soul society in the fight with the giant
ichimaru makes himself known to us
creating a goal and contrast for ichigo
forcing us to ask ourselves can i need
to go really tangle with this guy and
come out on top this is particularly
effective when we find out later that
ichimaro is the prime suspect of
something very mysterious going on
within the inner circle and once at the
safe house that launches them into the
inner walls we get offered tidbits of
interesting information about what to
expect inside and how to get there with
even their mastering of this new spell
offering kubo another clever means of
communicating their individual character
traits to us
orihime's bubble is shielding and
protective performed perfectly urdus is
slightly narrow but is getting there
chad's is powerful and strong but ichigo
is struggling and that's an important
observation when thought of alongside
the structure of this arc specifically i
think and one that sets it apart from
the arc before in a key way something
that massively differentiates this arc
from the last is in my estimation how
effective different scenes have become
the catharsis that we are allowed to
feel as readers has spiked considerably
within the soul society and i think it
has everything to do with the structure
of it the classical hero's journey
structure while both this arc and the
last could be seen as a single
continuous journey in many respects with
the first being evocative of elements of
the hero's journey format soul society
thus far is practically textbook in its
approach to that very structure rather
than simply being evocative of it while
the first saw ichigo accept a more
general call to action by rukia there
wasn't a definitive goal in mind or at
the very least a means outlined to get
there as compelling as the soul
society's arc provides while
entertaining and i think important to
the overall story the substitute
shinigami arc was more focused on
establishing the world and building up
the main players while dropping
significant bread crumbs concerning the
overarching narrative however with seoul
society ichigo quite literally needs to
accept a specific call to action to save
rukia he has to go through a number of
troubling physical and psychological
challenges to succeed on this journey
and most importantly by the ending he
will come out an entirely different
person changed for the better i hope and
i think due to this story once again
feeling more determined to tell one long
interconnected tale the build up along
with the ebbs and flows of this tension
makes for some of the most compelling
scene work bleach has had thus far
easily and once we do eventually get
inside just like the extreme contrast
between the likes of frieza and vegeta
or zorro versus mihawk earlier on in
their respective series there are
numerous extreme contrasts made to both
ichigo and the other company captains
that serve to communicate all we need to
set our expectations for the real meat
and potatoes of the story later on
however there is some other stuff i
noticed too not so good stuff but not
that bad either i've pointed out plenty
of instances of great exposition here in
the story but i have to be fair here too
so let's look at the other half
there's this scene with the captains
that provides examples of good and
unfortunately clunky exposition almost
side by side so i think it's good to use
this scene to show you what i'm talking
about the topic of conversation here
concerns ichimora's run-in with the
group at the gate alongside the giant
where he effectively just lets them go
despite him seemingly having the power
to not let that happen the good
exposition that takes place here comes
through ichimoro dealing with these
questions from the other captains why
did he not stop them how he reacts to
that question can be quite telling and
help us to infer his motives as a
character forcing us to ask questions
like what's he planning does he seem to
think of himself above others etc
however one of his excuses citing that
he didn't notice causes another captain
to say and i quote don't pretend you
don't know we of the captain class can
sense the disappearance of being spirit
energy now i can see it already people
saying that i'm nitpicking this one
instance but firstly it's not just this
one instance this sort of clunky overly
descriptive dialogue happens here and
there across many stories including
bleach more than once and secondly if
i'm going to go into the minutia of
details to praise small decisions like
at the beginning of this video i think
it's reasonable that i point out
shortcomings in the minutia of detail
too because this line is such a weird
thing to say to someone who should
already know and understand all of this
while also being in the company of a
group that already knows this too and
this stuff while minor does take me out
of the story somewhat now to be clear
having ichimaru say this to elicit this
sort of response isn't necessarily
something i take issue with being so
nonchalant about something like this
saying something you know will flag
people intentionally can tell us a lot
about how brazen this individual truly
is what his plans might be and where his
values might lie and while this line
about being able to send spirit energy
is an important piece of exposition for
us to know for sure in this arc it's
entirely unnatural in its delivery and
furthermore could have just been
demonstrated to us instead to put this
in perspective this would be like if you
walked downstairs and asked your mom
what's for dinner today and your mom
saying something like a nutritious meal
of course as human beings we need to
absorb the energy from other plants and
animals that populate this planet so as
not to perish ourselves while all of
that is technically correct it's not how
one would normally respond to another
question naturally and instead comes
across as a piece of dialogue used to
communicate how humans work to aliens it
always comes off strange however i will
concede that it is just a small gripe
and is nested within a rather intriguing
plotline one that does inject a
mysterious element to the plot that
genuinely adds an interesting ruffle of
uncertainty to my expectations for the
conclusion compelling me to keep reading
onwards as i learn more about the world
of the soul society it's ranked members
wrought with division and deceit and of
course rukia's ultimate fate however
i've spoken about the fringes for long
enough so i think it's about time i
analyze some of the action in this arc
too
[Music]
the action the genre of a particular
story in a sense and to varying degrees
can dictate how the story is most
effectively told in a murder mystery
interweaving the plot within the
mysterious is important in love stories
finding compelling means of interjecting
with valuable details is vital in more
slice of life scenarios and in shown in
stories as dragon ball does effectively
and dragon ball super did less
effectively fights and conflict are
often times the order of the day when it
comes to telling some really compelling
stories and as i've discovered bleach is
no different within this video's
material ichigo takes part in three of
the main fights that take place first
with ikaku second with renji and
eventually the third with kenpachi as
ichigo works his way from random ranked
members to assistant captains all the
way to full-blown powerhouses like
kenpachi the purpose of this stepping
stone type of progression through these
various enemies is not only to provide
ichigo with the necessary level of
competition as he gets more and more
powerful to keep things interesting but
to also tell in this case a three-part
story for ichigo to show where he's
beginning this journey to show him faced
with a lesson to learn and finally for
him to be faced with a mistake he's
making the enemies he faces in these
instances while taylor made to coax out
these particular elements of each
conflict the main piece they each bring
to the table is that of a stressor to
put enough pressure on ichigo such that
he's forced to look deep within himself
to uncover a truth he's been neglecting
so let's take a look at the first of
these three fights ikaku vs ichigo
acting as the premier contest for ichigo
to welcome him into the inner walls
initially what helps make this fight
interesting is a particular narrative
technique kubo is leveraging called
dramatic irony dramatic irony for those
that don't know is just a fancy way of
saying that we as an audience know and
understand something crucial that
another character in the scene or story
might not be aware of in this instance
we know that ichigo is likely to be more
than what ikaku is expecting stories
like one piece naruto hunter hunter
dragon ball ad nauseum utilize this
technique in their fights oftentimes
pitting a larger foe against a smaller
hero character to create an interesting
contrast in result this can be more
easily observed during urdu and
orihime's fight against their larger
adversary later on in the arc the fight
however between ikaku and ichigo is very
competitive but at the end of the day
the poor ikaku just didn't have what it
took to take down ichigo in this
instance the winner is ichigo something
this fight does reinforce is that ichigo
is genuinely a kind person refusing
point blank not only to kill ikaku but
also helps him to heal and waits for him
to wake i think i should point out also
here that when i said last week that
ichigo isn't the typical bombastic
shonen jump good boy i wasn't trying to
suggest that he wasn't a good person
he's clearly all of that however he has
much more of an edge to him than the
likes of goku luffy and naruto do i mean
there's a scene where ganju meets him
for the first time ganju grabs his face
and starts getting animated and in
response to this someone like goku luffy
naruto might say hey get off or what's
this guy's problem but ichigo foregoes
all of that and begins punching him in
the face i'm not saying ganju didn't
deserve it either i'm just saying that i
couldn't see that being the first course
of action for other more prototypical in
jump protagonists
renji vs ichigo following the first
fight ichigo's training has in his own
mind paid dividends so far so good and
narratively it set a baseline for us to
understand how he might measure up to
the remaining two fights as he graduates
from a lower ranked individual to a
number two of a company and while you
might be thinking he's bested renji
already as it happens in this realm he
isn't nerfed and is in fact five times
more powerful than he was on earth and
renji is viciously effective in this
battle and while a sizable amount of the
intrigue for the fight is shared between
ichigo and renji himself with him
fighting for a much more complicated set
of reasons as it's revealed how much
rukia has meant to him as well as the
history they share together through
various flashbacks it's the pressure
that he puts on ichigo that forces his
back into a corner flashing us back to
his training alongside mr kisuke who
explained that he needed to find a
resolve to follow through with what he's
asking of his weapon not to let fear
dictate how he feels but to instead
dictate to it what he is resolved to
have happened naturally ichigo does grow
from this experience identifying a hole
in his own game making for another
feather in his cap he thinks on this
journey to save his friend however in
actuality only opened him up for a much
more introspective encounter with his
blade later on the fight itself as well
as the action throughout these chapters
and indeed this arc feel like a massive
step up from the previous in both layout
and artwork layouts seem to be much more
adventurous without sacrificing clarity
all the while his artwork continues to
evolve from a more angular style to a
much more softer variant and while i'm
sure this might be a complaint for some
for me the fact that a single chapter
might cover just a decision or a
particular action being executed
effectively feels honestly quite
refreshing waiting week to week might
have been annoying but to me binging it
all in one go it feels good furthermore
we get more music
rinji's theme noro inu otherwise
translated to stray dog by hazu
featuring il bastino is also offered at
the end of one of these chapters being
one of the only tracks provided whose
lyrics are entirely japanese it's very
possible that kubo derived inspiration
for this character through those very
lyrics to which i would have great
difficulty deriving any significant
meaning however he probably did take
inspiration from these lyrics given that
kubo wrote descriptors like stray dog in
the manga itself a term used by renji to
describe himself during his flashback
with rukia as a child and coming of age
evocative of the themes of his song's
namesake the track is snappy rhythmic
with a driving lyrical accompaniment
that lends this team an air of authority
and confidence all the while the
instrumentation feels wily and
disconnected from the genre itself alone
violin emits the synth and percussion
cuts through the instrumentation and
unironically this track feels much more
like music i'd listen to in my down time
and is something i will most certainly
add to my playlist now before i move on
to the third best and final fight of
this video i'd like to touch on
something i've been alluding to and
praising throughout this first half of
the arc and that is
yeah
eisens killed much earlier in this story
one of the captains that seemed somewhat
sensible and kind eisen took cringy
aside and started to explore the
possibility that ruki's execution might
have something more to it her crimes
weren't worthy of such punishment her
location wasn't correlating with her
rank they changed protocol to move her
execution to a sooner date in time all
of these elements were honestly
fantastic and made me lean in all the
more while reading and to be honest
outside of the fights themselves given
that the main plot seems to be rather
straightforward this nefarious and
mysterious subplot of dissension amidst
the ranks of the soul society was
engrossing to say the least personally
my guess was that they were all doing
this in an effort to lure in ichigo i
mean he is the main character so it
stands to reason or at least someone
significant is trying to do this two
weeks ago perhaps unless i'm missing out
on some context here the idea of moving
all of these different things into place
for someone like rukia an adopted soul
reaper seems somewhat strange to say the
least but i suppose it is possible i
just might not know why yet but with
that said captain is then being made an
example of holy [__] that was a striking
narrative move but yeah that's the
situation now let's return to the action
by discussing what i thought of the
third and final fight
ichiko versus ken patchy after being
told about this particular and dangerous
captain's proclivities for finding the
strongest out of them and ignoring the
others i really enjoyed how kubo decided
to visually depict that search on the
page presenting this captain like some
sort of dark reaper or evil specter
looming around them at will until he
manages to find what he's looking for
ichigo and once he was finally revealed
he looks appropriately menacing sporting
a design as if inspired by a spider
offering a fittingly memorable
silhouette to boot this guy is totally
unlike anyone we've seen each go face
before he's clearly someone who's more
interested in a compelling fight with a
worthy adversary and kubo does a
phenomenal job in building kenpachi up
to be the monster he needs to be for
this first venture into the world of
captains in the soul society four ichigo
and while i do appreciate his
character's hidden complexities i
genuinely think that what he offers this
fight above all else is pressure for
ichigo to overcome
it is absurd how strong this guy is
leagues above everyone else we've seen
fights so far this is a captain and due
to that tremendous pressure ichigo is
offered the opportunity for the first
time to look deep within himself for the
answer as his blade manifests before him
leading to one of the coolest scenes
i've yet come across in this series this
is a really interesting chapter where
this manifestation of the blade asks him
a single simple question and once ichigo
answers transports him into another
plane of existence i genuinely have no
idea what this area is uh it sort of
reminds me of the mirror dimension from
doctor strange but in all honesty
judging by the dialogue shared towards
the end of this encounter i have my
theories because here he needs to fight
an alternative version of himself and
this is what i mean about kubo utilizing
the prototypical hero's journey
structure to great effect in that
structure typically i hear a most
overcoming flaw in his character through
great personal introspection or
sacrifice and in bleach to obtain the
means or strength to fight kenpachi
ichigo has to prove to himself that he
can get out of his own way in a sense or
at least that's what my interpretation
of this is in other words to take
control to overcome this sinister
looking entity standing in front of him
visually i love the stark contrast
between these two versions of ichigo and
i love the added touch of this
reflection on the blade of the alternate
ichigo it doesn't show the copy's exact
reflection but instead it shows a
version of ichigo frowning either
reflecting the real ichigo himself
presently or this copy is true feelings
it's a really cool idea also something
interesting i noticed was that he kept
on calling ichigo partner and i think
that's an interesting word because it
might be suggesting that this other half
of his isn't something he needs to
necessarily be in conflict with or fight
to suppress that in order to be an
effective warrior defender protector or
whatever sort of virtuous actor ichigo
wants to be he needs to utilize the
monster inside of him this was something
that could have been alluded to through
his transformation demonstrating how
close he is to the hollow inside him
also and now that i think of it the eyes
and color of this other ichigo seem to
match the hallow's color scheme made all
the more apparent as ichigo refers to
this white incarnation of himself and
the power of the blade he wields as
monstrous another curious choice of
words there reinforcing again the notion
that ichigo has something to embrace
from this other half through his
fighting style it's impossibly powerful
and ruthlessly creative as ichigo says
himself in ways that he wouldn't have
ever considered before
[Music]
and when one typically tries to master
their inner monster for the betterment
of society they of course run the risk
of losing themselves to this very task
this is of course speaking
philosophically i'm willing to admit
that i might be reading into something
that isn't there but with words like
monster and partner being used this
sinister looking entity proven to be
massively useful to ichigo showing him
things he otherwise never would have
thought of and of course that strange
reflection in the blade it does make me
wonder particularly when this dangerous
individual dematerializes returning to
zangetsu reinforcing that very notion
and theory i have that this is a part of
ichigo that needs to be dealt with at
some point in the future
[Music]
kenny's theme is super predators by
massive attack
[Music]
this song has a presence and i don't
describe songs like that very often if
this song was a person it'd beat you up
and steal your lunch money it's got this
domineering and thrashing synthetic
percussion and harmonic line to it but
by far the best part of this track i
think has to be its baseline the droning
persistent almost sinister nature of it
viscerally reminds me of jaws fittingly
entitled super predator as that
perfectly exemplifies what kimpachi is
to ichigo in this instance furthermore
this track gets extra points for being
written and performed by massive attack
for those of you that might not remember
this this was the band that performed
the song teardrop used to promote the
very first assassin's creed game back in
the day ah nostalgia with all that said
the action that i've seen in this fight
might be the best the manga has looked
so far from kenpachi's looming presence
at the beginning to the introspective
fight with ichigo's inner demon all the
way to their cataclysmic clash to cap
off this brilliant battle this was an
outstanding fight and one that leads
each go nicely to the goal of this arc
however before i touch on that i'd like
to address one small thing i do fully
intend on covering chad's fight from
earlier on the ark i'll just cover it
next week if that's okay ichigo recovers
and rukia's rescue
the conclusion to this first half i
thought was immensely satisfying having
followed hinataro and ganju's heroics to
get them to that point watching mr cat
turn into mrs cat and showing ichigo
arrive on the scene in the most dramatic
fashion right in the nick of time this
might be a strange comparison but that
scene where ichigo arrives the last
possible second to protect rukia reminds
me a lot of a particular save from the
berserk franchise between guts and casca
acting as yet another example of a
phenomenal artist making use of white
space to emphasize and bathe a moment in
the appropriate ambience now there's a
lot concerning this scene that i haven't
touched on yet and there's a specific
set of instances i'd like to draw
attention to more if i get the
opportunity to next week with the second
half of this arc the hollow mass that
continuously seems to be in the right
place at the right time to save ichigo
from death it's happened twice and thus
far seems to be in keeping with my
theory that embracing a more monstrous
nature isn't always a bad thing and that
on select occasions can in fact save
your very life but who knows if that
interpretation is accurate or not you
guys probably do but i have no idea
however if you would like to see my
thoughts on this ark's conclusion tune
in next week when i will finally finish
and give you all my impressions on the
concluding half of the soul society arc
will i think it sticks to landing will
it fall or will it fumble slightly only
time will tell but until then i've been
told mark i'll see you all next time and
thank you all so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you